so i woke up this morning and reviewed
some of my preferred sources
for the sort of like what happened
yesterday in right wing
media and came across something that
made me wonder
did we perfect time travel have we
traveled back
to the time when barack obama was
president
because on fox news propagandist sean
hannity
wasted no he's not even waiting for joe
biden to be sworn in
he wasted no time he is already warning
about
concentration camps that the left is
going to set up
for trump supporters uh they did this
under barack obama conspiracy theorists
and others talking about
a forced internment camps some of them
use the term
fema camps some of them actually use the
term
concentration camps and now this is
remember in a year when this is has this
has exploded
that today i am playing for you what i
believe is the start
of the biden will put trumpists
in concentration camps meme this is the
2021 version of it
and they never change their conspiracy
theories
they just change who it is that's going
to do it to you
sean hannity is saying they want to put
trumpists
in re-education camps take a look at
this
education camps deep programming okay
according to the press wing of the
democratic establishment party and the
socialist party
you we the people we need to be
deprogrammed or canceled or put in
re-education camps
because of our political opinion and it
differs from theirs
sadly after decades on tv and radio let
me just
tell you what this is really all about
now this effort
from the left it is not new it's only
accelerating
i'm not complaining but this has really
been my reality
now sean hannity is correct they do need
to be deprogrammed or reprogrammed
but a no serious leftist thinks putting
people in camps
is the way to deprogram uh trumpists i
i also like how he says this is the
dictate
from the socialist party what's what
socialist party
there's no one in power in the united
states from the socialist party
uh aoc claims to be a democratic
socialist and is really more of a social
democrat
what he's where where are these powerful
socialists hidden that they even have
influence in the united states
that's another red flag that maybe sean
hannity isn't actually telling you the
truth
and i i hate to tell you it pains me to
tell you this because it feels like
we're just rewinding back to 2015 2016.
um this stuff is going to go on for as
long as joe biden is president
the difference is you i i argue
that the difference about for example
concentration internment re-education
camp conspiracies in 2021 versus 2014
is that in 2014 way fewer people fell
for them
but the number of people that have
fallen for this q anon
wild trumpist stuff tells us that there
is a much
larger group of americans susceptible to
it today
than there was during president barack
obama's presidency and that's really
scary
that's something that we i don't know
how we deal with that
because we've got newsmax and oan
signal boosting it and um that you know
you did
you occasionally had internment camps
fema camps mentioned on fox news during
obama's presidency
but this is going to be the bread and
butter of newsmax of oan
and and of others now if sean hannity by
re-education camp
simply means we need to fix schools so
that people come out of school
better able to think for themselves not
susceptible to the propaganda of fox
news
and of oan and of newsmax then listen
guilty as charged
i want to improve education that's for
sure i want to be teaching critical
thinking
i want to be teaching uh epistemology
call
guilty is charged if what the allegation
is is that we want to
better educate people but consider the
irony
that they are the ones who have been
shouting lock them up
lock her up lock him up at rallies for
five years now
but the day before joe biden is sworn in
they go back to they're going to put
trumpists
in camps come on guys consider the irony
that they are the ones that came up with
and perpetuated
the war on drugs incarcerating uh
so many people for minor drug
infractions but they
say it's the left that wants to lock
people up in camps
what this doesn't even pass the sniff
test but as usual
with these people it's all projection
now one last thought
when we talk about radicalization and
what gets people to go out and try to do
real world violence
this is a perfect example beating people
over the head for months or years when
they want to put you in camps
they want to put you in camps because of
your political beliefs
this is what gets some people in their
audience some
to decide i'm going to go out and i'm
going to do something
horrible okay one very last thing i
thought i was on the last thing but i
have one more thing
you can only call it a re-education camp
if there's been education done before
for a lot of these people they're just
lacking the education to begin with
around a lot of these issues including
how government works
how to think critically how to
understand and interpret media messages
for yourself so
for many folks the education problem is
so bad that there's no re-education to
do there's been no education you say to
people
how do you determine whether a message
you see on the news is true or false
i don't know i've never thought about it
i've never devoted
nobody's ever given me a framework for
how to think about that
so this is a signal that much as we've
been predicting for months
it's all going back to the standard
republican playbook right-wing media
projecting on to the left the things
that actually would be better applied to
them
pretending to care about the budget and
pretending to care about small
government
and getting government out obstruction
uh religious freedom
first amendment explosions uh idiot
they're going back to the playbook so
buckle up for some crazy times
i was going to say we'll be covering it
once joe biden is sworn in but we're
covering it now
because they're wasting no time getting
started